hoy lunes 1º de marzo se conmemora el
día mundial del reciclado y terminamos
nuestra serie de reportajes dedicada a
esta población indispensable pero
invisible con la situación de los
recicladores en la ciudad de mexico en
la capital mexicana miles de personas
trabajan sin contrato y un salario fijo
este reportaje hace parte de la serie de
publicaciones resultados de la beca de
producción periodística sobre reciclaje
inclusiva ejecutada con el apoyo de la
fundación gabo y la actitud ere nos
informa yanine quirós y claudia
altamirano
en la ciudad de méxico más de 10.000
voluntarios participan en el servicio de
recolección de basura de manera informal
el gobierno local les llama voluntarios
porque trabajan precisamente de manera
voluntaria y con eso justifican que no
les den contrato ni salario fijo pedro
es uno de ellos entre los residuos que
separa y revende y la propina que recibe
de los residentes de la ciudad gana
entre 10 y 12 dólares al día por
propinas
bueno es que realmente es variable
puede haber días que nos salga un poco
más a veces menos pero dependiendo
también de las posibilidades de la gente
pero hay otros recicladores que no
reciben propinas y sobreviven sólo de la
venta de residuos al no tener contacto
con la población como patricia quien
trabaja en una planta de selección que
hay gente que design award call a
trabajar en la basura pero si supieran
que hay veces que nosotros que somos que
no tenemos en donde más trabaja somos de
donde nosotros tenemos y que si no
llegaran a cerrar oa quitar la basura ya
no a miles de personas se quedarían sin
trabajo los recicladores informales no
son reconocidos por las autoridades
locales lo único que obtienen de ellas
es el permiso para trabajar para esta
población marginada poder trabajar es el
único derecho que defienden que buscamos
con el gobierno pues que ahora que
tengamos la oportunidad de poder
trabajar que es lo esencial que es lo
que necesitamos para ser un
funcionamiento una labor aquí los
recicladores voluntarios
normales de la ciudad de mexico evitan
que casi 14 por ciento de los residuos
diarios vayan a rellenos sanitarios con
ello le ahorran al gobierno más de 6
millones de dólares al año según una
estimación a partir del inventario de
residuos 2019 un aporte ambiental y
económico que no es retribuido ni
reconocido en la ciudad más grande de
américa latina